hi I'm Steve Chu and I am back at
Stanford University having spent a four
and a quarter year sabbatical as US
Secretary of Energy I'm here to talk
about some renewable technologies that
can actually give us clean sustainable
energy and to mitigate the changes of
climate change where are we today well
wind has made dramatic progress in the
last 30 plus years from 1980 to today we
see the cause of wind plummeting and now
long-term contracts are being signed
today which are agreeing to sell wind
electrical energy at two-and-a-half to
three cents a kilowatt hour two utility
companies if you compare that to new
natural gas or coal if you build a new
natural gas plant today and assume that
natural gas over the lifetime of the
plant is $4 million Btu which is
historically very very low you'll find
that natural gas without wind subsidy is
comparable wind is already cheaper than
a new coal plant
what about solar energy this is what's
called a learning curve as you go and
you ship more and more solar modules out
the price gets lower and lower due to a
series of technological innovations the
slide was made in 2008 where they showed
where the price of solar modules was at
that time with a prediction by 2015 it's
beginning to approach wholesale cost of
electricity SMA perhaps to be 15 10
cents a kilowatt hour that projection
was incorrect what we see is that we've
already by 2015 actually reached grid
parity how do I notice look again at the
contracts being signed in 2008 the
contracts being signed were pricing
solar at 18 20 cents a kilowatt hour
four years later 2014 contracts being
signed in Texas pricing solar at five
cents and four point eight cents a
kilowatt hour grid parity amazing and so
solar energy is going to become lower
and lower as well as
when so as I came into the parm of
energy we said those are technologies
they're well on their path we will
continue to find research in them
because they're going to get better but
we are also seeking other disruptive
technologies and by that let me tell you
about first existing technology going
into the 20th century that existing
technology was a horse and buggy
there were innovations a steam-powered
car actually introduced before in the
1700s didn't work that well never took
on by the mid late 1800s the Benz
motovlog using a diesel internal
combustion engine it was a great car but
it wasn't disruptive because it cost too
much the disruptive technology was
technologically good and it met the
price and it was the actual Ford Model T
affordable by a large fraction of
Americans that actually began to replace
the horse and buggy is another example
we call this a transformational
technology and so the Tesla has won a
wonderful gray car but it costs $100,000
it will not be a mass marketed car we
need something like a Tesla that cost
twenty twenty-five thousand dollars and
that's what we're looking for and to
that end we're doing research and
batteries for example the Tesla battery
has about 250 watt hours per kilogram it
weighs 1,200 pounds and cost $30,000
that's a lot of money but there's a lot
of weight and we need a battery that has
five times higher energy density so it
weighs two or three hundred pounds and
then it has ten times faster charging
rate and my motto was we need a battery
that could be charged faster and could
last longer than the bladder that means
no one really drives 400 miles in one
sitting or very few people do they will
stop after 200 miles if they can charge
their car to go another 200 miles in
five minutes that's good enough what we
have today are batteries at this energy
density that weighs 1,200 pounds
the next generation battery
is being investigated by a number of
companies are with a silicon anode they
could maybe double the capacity and the
third generation would combine lithium
with sulfur which could again double it
so then we could have a battery instead
of weighing 1,200 pounds could wait a
couple hundred pounds 200 pounds same
weight as an internal combustion engine
and transmission and it could charge we
need a battery that can charge ten times
faster so that would be very exciting
another thing we began to think about in
the Department of Energy is as you see
the technology developing are you
prepared for the next thing so that is
for inexpensive renewable energy and
instead of being passive about this we
began to actively examine what happens
as the technology gets better and better
would it be self-limiting and let me
give you an example as we transition
from 10 or 15 percent renewable energy
which is where we are today 10 percent
to 50 percent you'll actually need a
much more flexible transmission and
distribution model I should also point
out when you're 50 percent intermittent
renewable energy you need backup power
so the cost of renewable energy actually
has to include that backup power which
is standby just in case the wind doesn't
blow the Sun doesn't shine
therefore renewable energy has to get
actually significantly less expensive
than new natural gas it is already
significantly less expensive than coal
but it's going to happen 10 and
certainly 20 years from today it will
happen so what else do we need
we need long distance transmission we
begin to need energy storage but the
good news is when we have 50%
intermittent energy there are days where
you will have lots of surplus energy and
indeed at night you can buy electricity
for example in California at 1/4 the
usual rate you buy electricity each
cells from somewhere between a half a
cent to two cents a kilowatt hour and
two decades from today I am confident
that we will be generating renewable
energy at two cents a kilowatt hour or
less so we have very inexpensive
electricity we can power and replace a
lot of fossil fuel but what else do we
need we need and this is a challenge we
need a new technology we need to be able
to take water and split it into hydrogen
and oxygen and then we need to capture
carbon dioxide very inexpensively again
we don't have the technology today but
there are a number of laboratories and a
number of companies that are developing
trying to develop technology that would
be four times less expensive at their
target price and the splitting of water
into hydrogen you then have the
ingredients for a real sustainable
energy that is to say you take water you
recycle carbon dioxide and what do you
do you take the water you split it into
hydrogen and oxygen
you take the carbon captured carbon
dioxide you have it undergo catalytic
transformation to build linear
hydrocarbon chains these hydrocarbon
chains are the molecules we use in jet
fuel and diesel fuel and in gasoline a
long distance transmission line is an
oil tanker we know that oil ships around
the world for a couple bucks a barrel
and so if we had this technology and a
very inexpensive electricity the energy
problem would be well on the way to
getting to true sustainability as I went
to Washington I confronted a embedded
established economy it's sort of like
the horse and buggy whip Lobby really
trying to tell Congress not to support
the development of automobiles that they
were dangerous and they would disrupt
the American Way of life similarly there
is this issue with the embedded fossil
fuel companies but as a scientist in
Washington it was my duty my mission to
dispassionately and calmly try to inform
people in
as well as others in government that
this is necessary it's going to take
decades we've got to do this but it will
ultimately be the low-cost option so let
me conclude of a picture one of my
favorites taking Christmas Eve 1968 it
was an Apollo 8 the first mission that
orbited the moon and the last orbit the
astronauts turned the capsule earthward
and they one of the astronauts took this
picture at which he called Earthrise
and Bill Anders the astronaut took the
pictures said we came all this way to
explore the moon and the most important
thing is we discovered the earth now if
you look at that picture it doesn't take
too much imagination to realize the moon
is not a good place to live from this
vantage point Earth looks very inviting
and guess what there's nowhere else to
go since 1968 we've discovered that the
climate is changing there is very
compelling evidence that a large part of
it is due to humans and we have to get
into a better position because really we
have to take care of the earth because
of us and our people and our
grandchildren and there's nowhere else
to go and so that's why I went to
Washington thank you